tu sais
cole
le monde bée ware
[Musique]
je sais pas vous mais il ya toujours des
marques avec lesquelles on crée un lien
et moi quand j'étais gamin il ya une
marque que je rêvais d'avoir quand j'ai
commencé la guitare quand j'avais 14 ans
était marshall je voulais d'abord un
ampli marshall peut-être parce que j'ai
dû voir plein d'artistes que j'aime et
avoir des amplis marshall peut-être
parce qu'en venant des tonnes de
concerts j'ai vu des amplis marshall
derrière est ce que c'est ça qui m'a
donné envie j'en sais absolument rien
mais toujours est il que quand j'ai
commencé la guitare maintenant d'acheter
une espèce de guitare trois francs six
sous et ce qui est normal quand on
commence la musique un ampli pareil et
qui était très très très très médium là
c'est criard et pierce que ça a été
possible
j'ai eu mon premier ampli marshall ça
c'est mon premier ampli marshall
je continue à avoir un lien avec cette
marque et je veux pas vous expliquer
pourquoi ça fait partie un peu des
choses un peu irrationnel dos comme
marchal est venu boire on a une nouvelle
fois en proposant qu'un monsieur on a un
nouveau casque atteint tester qu'est-ce
que tu serais tenté pour le tester je
dis bien évidemment marshall et nous
voilà donc avec un nouveau produit de la
marque c'est celui là c'est le monitor 2
à nc pour active noise cancelling c'est
à dire de la réduction de bruit active
tous fait un topo très rapidement et la
réduction brute passive jeu bouche les
oreilles je me casse traduction brûle
passive ça vient petit peu bloqué les
fréquences qu'à luxembourg objectif
c'est différent c'est à dire que vous
avez des micros extérieur qui vont venir
capter le son extérieur et qui vont
venir vous l'annulez par un système de
hors phase c'est très très simple à
comprendre
c'est comme quand vous faites des mac
vous avez plus sains et moins 1 vous
additionnez plus ans avec -1 et ça vous
fait zéro c'est exactement la même chose
avec leur phase on prend cette fréquence
là qui part vers le haut on voulait
inverse
on vous l'a fait partir vers le bas et
lorsque vous les mettez ensemble et bien
le son est plat y'a plus rien voilà le
principe de la théorie des réductions
louis active donc on un nouveau casque
est testée c'est celui-là le moniteur de
alors j'ai déjà testé depuis toujours il
est derrière moi
on va se faire un petit tour de ce
casque on va regarder s'il intéressant
de regarder s'ils marchent à la fin mon
boulot parce qu'il faut vraiment savoir
un truc c'est que là-dessus marshall a
vraiment mis de la barre extrêmement
haut est allé vraiment monté très haut
pour se battre face aux aux grands du
marché face aux pouvoirs en compétiteur
presse que marshall a réussi son pari
quelles sont les forces que sont été
blesse c'est ce qu'il faut acheter ce
produit est ce qu'il est intéressant est
ce qu'on retrouve l'adn de la marque
rock sont les gentes combat ensemble tu
on va commencer par jeter un coup d'oeil
au packaging
on retrouve effectivement le logo
molitor de ces noms à une sécheuse
expliqué réduction grouille active on
voit qu'ici on a ok google dont google
assisteront également syrie tout
d'utiliser un iphone ça me donne les
spécifications techniques du produit
cki noir sur blanc d'un traducteur de 40
mm une impédance de 32 ohms et une
fréquence qui va de 20 heures ce jusqu'à
20 milliards bon ça c'est un très très
grand classique packaging qui est
vraiment très sympa on retrouve vraiment
tout l'adn de marshall
c'est extrêmement rasées on vient de
lever comme ça il ya toujours un très
très beau boulot qui était fait par
marchal de toute façon au niveau du
packaging on le voit la voyez ça ressort
pas si le voyez bien moniteur 2 à une
c'est noir sur noir c'est très sympa à
l'intérieur vous allez retrouver ça ça
c'est le premier truc c'est un petit
étui de transport on à côté très tissus
au soudan un côté extrêmement roc en
hausse côte est qui ne peut pas tricher
qui est cousu qui est vraiment très très
original et moi j'adore ce qu'on va
trouver également à l'intérieur au
niveau du câblage c'est ça ça c'est les
prix jack jack pour brancher votre
casque sur n'importe quel smartphone
baladeur aux compagnies et surtout pour
trouver un petit peu dans l'adn de la
marque avec salah ça fait vraiment
penser aux prises jack pour monter sur
sa guitare sur son ampli qui vient
s'étirer pour nous également un câble de
recharge usb ce qui m'a sur le casque
avec d'autres côtés de l'usb ah ouais
surtout ce à l'intérieur ça c'est très
très très cool déjà parce que c'est un
joli casque qui respecte vraiment tous
les codes de marshall au niveau même de
la matière on sent vraiment à toucher un
peu comme lars aussi et qualitatifs cyr
en bourg et à l'intérieur c'est cool
le petit côté câbles entortillés vous
pouvez venir le mettre dans ce sens mais
vous pouvez également venir le tourner
et le met dans ce sens surtout il vient
ce repli est extrêmement facilement vous
prenez vous twister donc ça c'est génial
vous le mettez là dedans
et là vous partez ou vous voulez en plus
de sauf qu'à moi je trouve très léger
avec à peine 320 g mais il est surtout
extrêmement confortable je repars hôtel
à gauche je le mets leur doyenne le
règle vraiment à ma tête déjà comme ça
j'ai une bonne réduction brute passive
je trouve léger il n'ya pas m'encombrer
et surtout que j'aime beaucoup et c'est
est ce que là c'est que il vient
vraiment prendre la forme de votre
oreille épouser la forme de votre
oreille alors après ça dépend une fois
de plus de la morphologie de chacun mais
chez moi il vient l'englobé petit
coussinet à mémoire de forme sur le
dessus aussi bon qu'au terme de confort
c'est vraiment bien on repère facilement
la droite de la gauche vous l'avez ici
la regarder le petit wright
ici le petit lev t il ya un truc qui est
vachement intéressant c'est les boutons
alors ça c'est surprenant parce qu'en
fait marshall nous a dit si vous voyez
une petite commande un peu joystick qui
vachement intuitive vous comprenez qu'en
appuyant et bien ça nous fait plaise
pour appuyer sa bouffée pose bon ça on
le devine après nous on comprendre avec
un appui long ça vient vous l'éteindre
lorsqu'on les fait un morceau suivant
hop vous avancez paris six morceaux
précédents vous revenez en arrière vous
voulez monter le volume vous pousser
vers le haut baisser le volume
vous allez vers le bas on comprend très
très très facilement le sens de ce
bouton et ça c'est bien parce qu'un
certain caste qui ont des commandes
tactiles plus ou moins évidente ça tout
de suite c'est extrêmement évident
maintenant la question c'est est-ce que
ce bouton est vraiment très robuste dans
le temps et se risque pas de prendre des
mauvais choc si vous le coincé quelque
part vous fait pas suffisamment
attention votre casque c'est le point
d'interrogation
en attendant sur le principe de côté
purement utilisation je trouve ça
vraiment bien
vous avez un autre bouton qui est
planqué juste ici c'est le bouton m le
bouton m il vous sert pour naviguer
entre trois pré réglages des quizz
heures tout mon travail c'était
l'application mais ce bouton marshall
vous pouvez venir le paramétrer parce
que oui pouvez venir la signer votre
assistant vocal et un autre bouton qui
planquaient juste ici ces boutons à nc
lorsque vous appuyez d'une fois et bien
c'est la réduction brute qui active et
ça marche deuxième bouton c'est le ce
qu'on appelle le mode monitoring qui
vous permet d'entendre ce que vous avez
autour de vous ce qui se passe avec les
micros vous avez dans votre caste vont
venir récupérer le son vol injectés dans
votre casque pour vous entendiez ce qui
passe à côté de vous tandis que si vous
appuyez une troisième fois
ça vient tout simplement désactiver la
réduction brute il ya tout sens qu'elle
marshall a été très très loin même au
niveau du détail agence a vachement bien
dans le côté rock l'univers rots et les
sons lorsque vous aller allumer votre
caf lorsque vous allez utiliser euros
cette petite molette là attendez je vais
vous laisser écouter vous attendez le
son des guitares s'avoue fan chérif et
lorsque jeu rapide su en fait ça fait un
petit saut comme si on passait sur les
cordes guitare avec le médiator et
lorsque j à éteindre c'est la même chose
qu du doubs donc tout ça c'est plutôt
bien
mais ce qu'on vient avant tout chercher
sur un casque c'est la qualité audio on
veut une excellente qualité audio
surtout à un casque qui coûte génétique
notre partenaire clé pour ça que je me
laisse 299 euros alors qu'est ce que
vaut ce casque en terme l'expérience
audio est ce qu'il est à la hauteur
oui ou non mais vous allez voir c'est
justement là où ça devient extrêmement
intéressant parce que oui
marshall a fait un bon boulot niveau de
ce casque la qualité audio est là il ya
plusieurs points de nuances mais je vais
vous expliquer la première chose c'est
vous prenez le cast vous le posez sur
les oreilles vous l'écoutez hop je mets
sur les oreilles avec la réduction brute
active jeune homme entend absolument pub
j'ai hurlé on inspecte qui est assez
équilibré on a des graves qui sont
présents les médiums sont également
présents on les distingue bien on a de
la finesse au niveau des aigus
pour tout ce qu'on va retrouver jeudi au
niveau des cymbales deux sont
extrêmement claires et sur une montée en
fréquence donc ça marche
le spectre est cohérent le spectre est
large et ça c'est bien il si on a un
codec sc on aurait pu s'attendre à voir
encore un petit peu mieux son à vue de
la paix pic de qualcomm
mais déjà comme ça de base ça fait tilt
a maintenant il ya une nuance
lorsque vous à l'écouté au casque avec
la réduction bruit active et où la
réduction bruit désactivé il ya un
changement qui s'opère au niveau des
sons graves réduction brouille active
vous avez des graphes ils sont présents
ils sont beaux vous coupez la réduction
brute vous perdez c'est grave
ils disparaissent légèrement et c'est
moins terrible j'arrive pas à comprendre
pourquoi je puis vous assurer qu'il ya
une vraie différence c'est qu'elle est
là de toute façon lorsqu'on va utiliser
ce cas ce que là ce qu'on recherche
avant tout c'est la réduction proactive
donc celle là vous allez profiter de la
meilleure expérience bien évidemment son
légende bien évidemment marshall
marshall rock'n'roll mais vous pouvez
écouter autre chose
vous pouvez écouter du hip hop comme
vous avez des graves qui sont présents
et bien ça doit groove et ça va être
bien vous allez pouvoir écouter
également du jazz avec beaucoup de
finesse dans quel que soit ce que vous
allez rechercher en terme de fréquence
vous allez trouver ça c'est de base mais
si vous voulez les encore plus loin il
ya un truc qui est vachement cool c'est
l'équateur dans l'application voilà donc
votre application
je vois le niveau de batterie il est
connecté vous avez deux choses que vous
voyez en bas qui sont des commandes
principales et ku celle équaliseur les
co leaders numéro un bis à 300 votre
bouton m en première position sur votre
casse et bien c'est le saut marshall ses
leçons que marshall a choisi avait
quelque chose qui est extrêmement plein
vous avez un son numéro 2 qui un sont
personnalisées et ensuite un faux numéro
3 bon c'est la même chose vous venez de
régler vous le personnaliser alors moi
sur le son numéro deux ce que j'ai
souhaité faire c'est monté légèrement
les basses sur la fréquence de 160 hertz
tout simplement pour venir chercher un
peu plus de groupes en fonction des
morceaux après pouvait venir choisir
rock spoken pop hip hop électronique
jazz je suis pas un grand fan des
paramètres qui ont été créés c'est
beaucoup mais que vient faire par vous
même le truc que j'ai regrettés là
dessus maintenant c'est que vous avez
que cinq bandes 160 r ce qui va vraiment
être les fréquences les plus gras 400
hertz et du médium grave 1 kg ça va être
le son médium 2 kg 5 c'est plus le son
de la voix également es16 25 km ce qui
va être plus pour les médiums aigus
j'aurais bien aimé qu'on une fréquence à
10 kg pour ni réhaussé tout ce qui va
être cymbales sons très aigus comprise
ni un petit peu plus chercher c'est un
peu dommage par contre il ya un truc qui
est vachement intéressant là dessus et
qu'à prendre vraiment une spécificité au
produit c'est qu'en fait c'est et ku qui
fonctionne pas comme tous les écueils
que j'ai pu connaître sur le marché et
c'est là que ça devient intéressant je
vous explique un peu l'histoire par
principe
vous avez toutes vos bandes de
fréquences que vous ayez un trente deux
bandes de fréquences ou que vous ayez un
cinq bandits si c'est le même principe
vous avez votre son vous venez soit
monté une fréquence soit là décès soit
rajouter quelque chose qui manque soit
corriger un défaut et vous venez
l'enlever c'est comme ça que marche un
équaliseur que ce soit pour le milieu
professionnel ou même vous pour votre
casque la différence que vous allez voir
ici c'est la pente puisque vous venez
monter une bande de fréquences qui est
extrêmement large
votre spectre va vraiment venir se
rapprocher de ça et ça vient casser le
reste c'est à dire que puisque ce que je
montre là c'est très large tout ce qui
va être aiguë je veux voir l'envers dans
l'écran tout ce qui va être élu ici eh
bien ça va être diminuée et tout ce qui
va être graves ça va être diminuée donc
on va vraiment avoir un réglage qui est
complètement différent si vous aviez par
exemple un équaliseur avec beaucoup plus
de bordeaux et on sent réellement
donc si vous voulez vraiment monter une
fréquence médium il faut venir contre
balancer et corriger aussi pour remonter
un petit peu grave sans quoi ils
disparaissent et c'est la même chose
pour les aigus faut vraiment faire
confiance à vos oreilles pour trouver
exactement ce que vous voulez donc dans
le principe c'est marrant pourquoi pas
mais dans cette application vous permet
de faire autre chose c'est ici la petite
partie vous a trouvé à nc pour la
réduction bruit à l'envoyer là je suis
sur la réduction de bruit qui en marche
qui fonctionne qui activaient je peux
venir régler 100% et je peux venir
diminué je peux kalema réduction de
bruit comme je souhaite ensuite gène
mode monitoring
alors ça c'est pareil fait ajuster la
transparence du mode monitoring soit je
veux vraiment entendre beaucoup ce qui
se passe à l'extérieur autant que les
marsan pour s'en venir régler le volume
audio qui va être injectés par les
micros dans mon casque et ensuite j'ai
un mode ici où je dis à l'éteindre
mon petit bouton m que je peux venir
paramétrer je vous en parlais tout à
l'heure surtout qui est vachement
intéressant je peux venir choisir soit
d'avoir mes équaliseur avec mes
paramètres 1 2 3 c'est ce que je vais
retrouver lorsque je suis ici au niveau
de mai et cube soit sur le bouton m je
peux venir choisir de mettre google
assistant parce que la chute sur une
application ios mais existe également
sur android et sur ios via petite
particularité d'utiliser bouton pour par
la série minutes heure d'arrêt
automatique
si par exemple j'écoute de la musique le
soir avec des sites demandant mais au
bout d'un moment eh bien vous mettez un
petit minuteur dans combien de temps
votre casque s'éteindra tout ça c'est
bien mais quand les types de l'autonomie
elle est reçue marshall a fait aussi un
boulot intéressant puisque vous avez une
autonomie qui est dantesque ce à dire
que vous allez prendre votre casque vous
allez le connecter en bluetooth
réduction du activé vous pouvez aller
jusqu'à 30 heures d'autonomie je sais
pas si vous vous rendez compte ça me
permet de faire presque le tour de la
cage sans aucun problème et si vous
activer la réduction brute mais que vous
le collecter toujours en bluetooth
eh bien vous monter jusqu'à 45 heures
d'autonomie c'est énorme
et si vous êtes à cours batterie au
moment de partir vous le charger un
quart d'heure et vous partez pour 5
heures d'écouté et si vous voulez les
charger complètement de 0 à 100% il vous
faudra deux heures et pour la recharge
ça se passe ici en usb c'est bon vous
voyez marshall a quand même sorti le
grand jeu pour son casque avec un côté
nomade avec une boîte qui est bien avec
un casque qui est racée qui reste
vraiment dans les codes de marchal sont
légende rock'n'roll et compagnie je vous
en passe on a une portée de 10 mètres à
grâce au bluetooth 5.0 ce que j'ai
regretté ici c'est qu'on n'est pas
d'appétit x de qualcomm notamment par
rapport à ce qu'on trouvait en face à la
concurrence qui se trouvait sur un
marché et sur une gamme de prix où il ya
des acteurs majeurs c'est le petit bémol
que je pourrais lui conférer parce que
je trouve que dans l'ensemble
l'expérience est vraiment top
le fait d'avoir ce petit bouton
extrêmement intuitif le petit côté doré
qui restent dans les codes marshall par
rapport à ce que vous avez sur un ampli
notamment sur le graphe state
s'engagerait play paris sur le bal ce
raid 100 m daria je trouve ça bien et
tout ça je vous dis pour l'avoir il
faudra débourser la modique somme de
modiques entre guillemets bien
évidemment de 299 euros
d'ailleurs si vous intéresse j'ai mis un
lien dans la description a vous de me
dire maintenant comment vous le trouvez
comment vous trouvez ce cas ce que la de
marshall ils ont vraiment fait une
superbe montée en ga en restant dans ce
qu'ils savent faire en ayant un côté
très compactes dites moi s'il peut vous
intéresser si vous avez des questions ou
interrogations sous gestion et je vous
invite bien évidemment à vous abonner et
à l'insécurité parce qu'on va continuer
à parler texte sur ce je vous embrasse
son amour des gros bisous de l'amour
solidays
[Musique]
à cet effet